[MUSIC PLAYING]
BILL LUAN: Shanghai
DJ is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This
is primarily a
question-and-answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions.
ALI AFSHAR: Hello, everyone.
Welcome to Google Drive Live.
My name is Ali, and I'm joined
today with Steve.
STEVE BAZYL: Hi, everyone.
ALI AFSHAR: And today we're
going to talk to you a bit
about the differences between
Google Drive and a
conventional or traditional file
system as you would have
on your hard disks at home.
We're going to explore a range
of topics, mostly based around
the use cases and why you'd want
to look at it this way.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, I've gotten
this question from a lot of
developers, some who are just
looking to integrate with
Drive from a fairly
straightforward integration
but are just new to the
model that Drive has.
But there's also some really
cool use cases with like sync
clients, virtual file systems,
all sorts of
things people can do.
ALI AFSHAR: So should we just
talk about them very briefly?
What do you mean by a
virtual file system?
STEVE BAZYL: So I know there's
actually an open-source
project that somebody's
started working on.
It's a fuse adapter for Drive
basically to make Drive look
like a local file system.
Personally, I actually started
playing around with doing this
with the HTML5 file system and
see if I could do a shim that
makes Drive appear like any
other file system in
JavaScript.
ALI AFSHAR: Cool.
STEVE BAZYL: And I don't know
about sync clients, but rumor
has it you were playing
around with one?
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah, so a sync
client is essentially an
application that runs on your
local machine that mirrors
what's in Drive.
And that's another use
case for this.
And really anything, any
situation where you're using a
conventional local file system,
you should consider
what would happen if I swapped
out the local file system and
replaced it with a cloud
file system like Drive.
How would you go about
doing that?
STEVE BAZYL: So before we go
into some of the challenges,
what do you think some of the
key differences are with Drive
and a regular file system?
ALI AFSHAR: Well, my favorite
one is that you can run out of
hard drive space, but you can
never run out of Drive.
STEVE BAZYL: Well, that's
not entirely true.
There's quota.
ALI AFSHAR: There's quota.
STEVE BAZYL: You do have
to pay for it.
ALI AFSHAR: Exactly.
But that's my favorite one.
But apart from that, the
structure is slightly different.
Anything you want
to say about--
STEVE BAZYL: Well, probably
the biggest one is paths.
I mean, everything in Drive is
really identified by unique a
identifier.
It's basically a UUID for that
file as opposed to a path like
you would have on a normal
file system.
So that does creates some
challenges when you are
expecting it to behave
like a file system.
ALI AFSHAR: Right.
So does that mean all your
files are flat and
they have an ID?
STEVE BAZYL: No, no.
We do have parents, which
basically are labels.
But we present them like
folders in the UI.
And parents can be inside
other parents.
And you can build up path-like
structures.
But the concept of
path-addressable files is
something that is missing in
Drive compared to a normal
file system.
So if you wanted to look up a
file by /who/bar/myfile.text,
you'd have to do a little
bit of work.
ALI AFSHAR: Right.
So, OK, first use case.
The standard thing you want
to do with a file system.
Say you have a directory, a
folder with some files, and
you want to list them.
STEVE BAZYL: Generally, pretty
straightforward to list.
It's basically files.list
in the API.
But file systems have
some different rules
than what Drive has.
The biggest one that comes to
mind is the fact that the file
names in Drive don't
have to be unique.
ALI AFSHAR: Right.
STEVE BAZYL: So if you require
file names to be unique
because you're trying to
impersonate a file system, you
have to figure out how do you
disambiguate two files with
the same name.
ALI AFSHAR: So any
thoughts on that?
How would you go about
doing that?
STEVE BAZYL: Well, I know, for
example, the sync client
that's available with Drive
uses, I believe, the file
creation date.
In the case that it detects two
files with the same name,
it will append to one of
them the creation time.
It's nice, because it gives you
a nice stable ID that's
not going to change in between
new files getting
added and so on.
But when I was playing around
the file system or doing this
in JavaScript, I did
run into a few
issues with that, though.
It's actually not quite as
simple as it sounds.
ALI AFSHAR: Like what
kind of issues?
Well, so one of them is if you
take a look at the HTML5 file
system, for example, it
encourages paging.
And so when I was first
approaching this, I thought,
well, I'll just take pages from
Google Drive as I get
those results.
And I will just call the
callback every time I get a
new set of results, that I could
keep doing this and have
a nice responsive API.
The problem is, in order to do
the disambiguation reliably,
you really want to make sure
that the files are always
going to be returned back
in the same order.
Because if you're doing this on
the fly, you can certainly
keep track of all the ones
you've seen, and the next time
you get a duplicate,
change that name.
But if the files come out of
order, every time the user
refreshes, file names are
going to come back.
And sometimes file A will have
the time stamp, sometimes file
B will have the time
stamp, and it
can get kind of confusing.
ALI AFSHAR: I see.
So I had this similar problem
when trying to write a client
that simulates synchronizing
like this.
I actually opted to disambiguate
just by adding a
1 or a 2 in brackets.
STEVE BAZYL: But you still
have the same fundamental
issue, though, that you
want that name to be
as stable as possible.
ALI AFSHAR: Exactly.
So I ignored the fact that
it could be stable.
I said, OK, well, I'm not
going to win there.
Instead, I'll have to store a
set of metadata myself in a
database, which sets the
absolute path on the local
file system and the ID of the
file on Google Drive.
And because of that, it means,
well, either can change, and
it doesn't matter, because
I wont to lose
track of what's happened.
STEVE BAZYL: Exactly.
And that is an option that
I was looking at on the
JavaScript side as well as
using local storage or
something as a cache so it can
keep track of some of this
data in something that's
persistent to that client.
So at least in between directory
calls, even if the
files change order, I
can still map them
back to the same name.
So actually, if you have the
option of local storage, that
actually works out to be
a pretty nice solution.
ALI AFSHAR: And if you don't
have that, well, then it's
going to be a bit
tricky, I guess.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, you
end up having to
either do what you said.
You just don't worry about it,
or you have to do things like
buffer up all the results, fetch
all your pages, sort on
the client side.
And then you can make
sure that you have a
stable name that way.
ALI AFSHAR: So--
STEVE BAZYL: --with a little
bit of extra work.
ALI AFSHAR: --this is one
of our big fundamental
differences, is that
you get all the
files in a file system.
You can get them at the same
time, but you have to use
paging in Google Drive.
STEVE BAZYL: Right.
Because it is a remote
service.
The response time is
significantly longer than if
you were doing this on
a local file system.
So paging is really important if
you want to have that user
responsiveness where you can
return back the first 50
results or so very quickly.
And then as the user continues
on, keep fetching.
If you try to batch out a
2000-file directory, you're
talking several seconds
of wait time.
ALI AFSHAR: Right, which leads
us nicely on to the next
point, is that when you're
developing for a local file
system, you can really assume
that your calls are going to
come back almost immediately--
not really immediately, but
almost immediately.
So a lot of local file system
programming just involves
synchronous calls that blocks
until it returns.
And you imagine that actually
that's not really going to
take too long.
STEVE BAZYL: Right.
Exactly.
ALI AFSHAR: With Google Drive
or any remote file system,
really, you have to build this
into whatever you're doing.
You have to put it into the
core, and it has to be
asynchronous.
So you have to say, go and do
this, and then when it's done,
tell me about it, and I'll
do something there.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, exactly.
And that was another case where
it was actually easier
when trying to do the file
system in JavaScript.
Because that API is
asynchronous, it was a very
nice match.
There is actually a synchronous
version of that
API that I didn't even attempt
to try just because trying to
do that and make this inherently
asynchronous
process appear synchronous was
too much work for what I was
trying to do at the time, and
mostly just an experiment.
ALI AFSHAR: And really important
for graphical
applications.
Because usually these
things run in a
single thread by standard.
And if you want to block that
thread, you're going to block
everything.
You know, the hover buttons
aren't going to work, and
menus are going to crash, and
windows are going to go that
nasty grey color.
So really, really
important here.
And modern operating systems,
Android specifically, it won't
let you make blocking
calls like this.
So you really have to bake
it in from the start.
STEVE BAZYL: Yep, definitely.
So another area that was less
important for sync clients,
more for virtual file systems,
if you're doing a Fuse file
system or anything like
that, is file paths.
So just one thing that's just
not in Drive is the ability to
address a file via path.
And actually, this does relate
a little bit to the issue of
disambiguation because in
these cases of file-name
conflicts, we're doing all this
resolution on the client
side in terms of detecting if
two file names have the same
name or two folders have the
same name and creating a
unique one.
Whatever names we assign aren't
really known by the
drive server.
So we can't address those
files with those
disambiguated paths.
So it does create a little
bit of an issue.
It's not a lot of work, but you
do have to do be able to
handle that traversal on the
client side and be able to
resolve parent and so on.
But this is also a case where
local storage actually ends up
being really handy because you
can basically build up a cache
of paths mapped to file IDs so
that you can resolve those
entirely on the client.
ALI AFSHAR: So did you find an
elegant way to do the paths?
Or were you just snipping a bit
off it each time and just
going through?
STEVE BAZYL: So I actually
tried a few different
strategies.
You probably did as well.
ALI AFSHAR: Well, I'm
interested to
know what you did.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah.
Yeah, so the two strategies I
was looking at was-- one was
basically just traversing with
each step in the path.
Keeping track of relative
paths as
well, is really important.
But for things that I didn't
have cached, yeah, it would
have to be go and
fetch this item.
And if it's a folder and
there's more path, keep
traversing.
And it ends up being
several calls.
Obviously, each part of the path
is another remote call.
So it actually can get very
expensive if you're trying to
traverse a really,
really deep path.
The other approach, which was
much, much more performant but
takes a little bit more to
actually set it up and get it
to work reliably was kind of
what I mentioned earlier--
building up a cache or basically
a mapping of full
paths to their file ID, so that
as I traverse directories
and retrieve files, I would
just store that path
and that file ID.
So if I ever needed to reference
it, I could do that.
Or if I at least have part of
the parent, I can at least
shortcut part of that lookup.
So maybe I don't have the full
path, but I'll at least have
one or two of the directories
in there.
ALI AFSHAR: So you just that
whole path as a single string,
essentially.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, and do things
like prefix matching
and so on, but, you know,
ways that you can save a
little bit of work.
But again, a lot of that
requires doing either--
kind of building it up on the
fly, in which case you have to
deal with misses and try
to traverse it any way.
Or another thing I was
looking at was
combining the changes feed.
So basically doing one upfront
huge query to basically build
all the paths and then using
the changes feed
to keep up to date.
So if things get moved around,
then I can just update that
without having to query--
ALI AFSHAR: I see.
STEVE BAZYL: --a folder
every time that I
wanted to get its content.
ALI AFSHAR: So the changes
feed is one of those nice
things that--
we have more features in Google
Drive than a regular
file system.
And obviously, we can keep
adding features to it.
Whereas a file system is pretty
much something that is
there and it's not really
going to change.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, it's a really
useful feature for
these types of cases,
particularly sync clients.
I mean, the heart of a sync
client is the changes feed.
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah, absolutely.
So, I mean, how the
sync client works
is, well, it's two-way.
The first one, we
have to monitor
changes on the file system.
And the second one, we have to
monitor changes in Drive.
Now, you can do changes
on the file system.
The different operating systems
have very much their
own specific thing for that
so that they can do that.
Windows has its own.
Mac OS has its own.
And on Linux, you use inotify
or something like this.
So we have that baked
into Google Drive.
So it's called the
changes feed.
And you say what has changed
in the user's Google Drive
since a certain point in time?
And everything that has changed
since then is returned.
And that's how we were doing it
to check changes that have
happened then.
Obviously, there's going to be
problems because if someone
changes a file in both places at
the same time, what are you
going to do in that situation?
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, and that's
actually a good question.
So one of the other issues
related to paths and
everything is the fact
that a file can
have multiple parents.
And for the most part, at least
when I was doing some
stuff with the file system, this
wasn't a huge problem.
It's not that much different
than having, say, symlinks,
for example.
Just a file happens to exist
in two directories.
I imagine, though, for the sync
client, that's probably a
little bit more of a
challenge, though.
There might be some
edge cases--
probably really rare edge cases,
but things where you
have concurrent edits of the
file locally, then you have to
resolve those.
ALI AFSHAR: So that is
a problem, really?
Which one wins?
Who is the real file, and
who is the symlink?
So just to go over multiple
parents as we have in Drive,
just to explain that properly.
A file can be in many different
folders at the same time.
And Steve mentioned it,
they're just labels.
They're just like
tags or labels.
You can put them in as
many as you like.
So when you synchronize that
down to the local file system,
which one is a copy, which
one is the actual file?
I just solved it by putting
a copy of the
file in both places.
And then if the file changed
in either place, I would
update it remotely and in
both those locations.
I'm not sure that's
the greatest
solution, to be honest.
STEVE BAZYL: So, if you had two
near-simultaneous edits?
ALI AFSHAR: Right.
STEVE BAZYL: Which
one would you--
is it last in?
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah, the last
in, the last in.
STEVE BAZYL: So basically the
same as doing the resolution
for the remote copy as well.
ALI AFSHAR: I mean, how the sync
client works is it tries
on that very level of
disambiguatiing it, it tries
to run it all in a single queue
so that you never get
race conditions there.
So the last one would win
because it would just happen
after the more previous one.
Not ideal.
And that's why my sync client
was just a learning experience
or something like that.
The real Google sync clients
spend a lot of code trying to
handle these cases like this.
STEVE BAZYL: So one of the
cases that comes up--
I know I've talked to a couple
developers who've written
their own sync processes
and so on is--
time stamping.
And so it's actually really
important in terms of suppose
you have a local edit on the
file, making sure that that
edit time is reflected
in Drive instead
of the upload time.
And is that something that
developers can do
if they need to?
You said to make sure
that edit times
and creation times--
ALI AFSHAR: I think the
creation time is set.
But the edit time, I think you
can set that yourself.
STEVE BAZYL: You can
override that?
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah, you
can override that.
I'm not exactly sure
about that.
But yeah, that is really,
really important.
So you want to know when the
file was last edited,
actually, by a user, not by the
last time it was uploaded
to our server.
So useful use case.
And we offer other ways
of finding out
has the final changed.
STEVE BAZYL: Right, as
like the MD5 hash.
ALI AFSHAR: The MD5
hash, right.
STEVE BAZYL: So very, very easy
to calculate, so a good
way to check did the
metadata change?
Or this is actually content
that's fresh and needs to be
downloaded?
So anything else that you
can think of or--
ALI AFSHAR: Well, and I can
really only think of
advantages of things than Google
Drive has that a local
file system doesn't have.
STEVE BAZYL: All right.
Such as?
ALI AFSHAR: Such as we have all
this additional metadata
that's amazingly useful.
Obviously, on a file system,
you have the name.
You have the size of the file.
You can get the permissions.
That's pretty much
it without using
third-party tools to do stuff.
But we store things such as the
extension of the file, the
MIME type of the file.
That can be an absolute
nightmare to work out
yourselves, the MD5 hash,
as you mentioned.
And then we have ways in which
you can convert the file or
export the file or look if it's
a video, for example,
stream the file immediately, the
kind of benefits you can
only really get from a
cloud file system.
STEVE BAZYL: Actually, that
does the raise something.
There are certain files in
Drive that aren't really
files, right?
So they are things like Google
Docs, presentations,
spreadsheets--
ALI AFSHAR: Folders?
STEVE BAZYL: --folders,
shortcuts for third-party apps
that everyone out there
is building.
How do these behave
differently?
ALI AFSHAR: Well, there's no
binary content in these.
So by binary content, you know
the files data, there's
nothing there.
So a folder is just a
placeholder with a specific
MIME type so that we know it's
a placeholder, and it can be
used as a parent.
And the more interesting
case are these links.
Some of them are Google Docs,
and some of them are
third-party linked files.
So what do we get in
that situation?
Well, all you can put on the
local file system is
a URL to the file.
Now what could that URL
do, for example?
It could open up the file in the
remote application, in the
third-party application, or
in Google Docs, Google
spreadsheets.
We could probably do a bit
better than that, couldn't we?
What do you think?
STEVE BAZYL: Ah, yeah,
they probably could.
So one of the issues with the
current way it works has to
do, I think, with OAuth
implementation, the way that
we initiate the process.
It's not really friendly right
now to offline access.
There are cases where-- one
feature I would love to see is
almost like shadow documents,
where it's like you could have
the content in a third-party
system, in a database, but
quietly in the background
keep data up to sync.
So you always have
that export.
You always have a binary
data that you can
download and use locally.
You can use it offline.
Something like that would
actually be kind of cool.
But as it is now, the URL
feature works pretty well
because you can click on one of
these .glink files, open it
up in a browser, and use the
app and launch it from the
file system just the same way
as if you launched it
from the Drive UI.
So it's actually pretty cool
the way it works right now.
ALI AFSHAR: I mean, that's
really nice in the case where
you don't have a
native editor.
And by native editor, I mean
something that will run on
your PC or your Android
or whatever.
And so if there is a native
editor exists, say, for
example, I don't know, a text
editor that you can run on
your local machine as well,
you'd probably like to use the
local version.
It just would give you
a better experience.
And these days, still,
unfortunately native apps
sometimes do feel a bit
better than web apps.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, and this is a
criticism I've heard of even
our own editors.
So, for example, having a Word
doc in Drive, in order to that
in our document editor, it
has to be converted.
But then you lose that ability
to sync those changes back
into the binary representation
of it.
So having a little bit more
seamless support for switching
between binary file for local or
for data maps, and then the
online-only, more collaborative
version for when
you're on the web, that would
actually be an ideal case.
ALI AFSHAR: That's
something I would
really like to see there.
STEVE BAZYL: It's also a really
hard technical problem.
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah really,
really hard.
It would also solve a lot
of the offline issues.
Say you lose web access.
That might be something that
would be really useful.
STEVE BAZYL: Something that we
can certainly suggest to the
engineering team, but I know
there have been some
conversations.
And it's not the easiest
thing to tackle.
ALI AFSHAR: Especially since
there are so many platforms.
Sometimes you'll find an
app that's available
for all these platforms.
Which one should you launch?
The authorization issue, as you
mentioned, that's also huge.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, and it's also
very hard to do this in a
way that's not loss-y.
Every time you do a conversion
between these formats, there's
always that potential that
there's some item that's not
going to map well.
So you really want to do that
well and fix the issues that
you run into in terms of the
conversion, and then work in
the new format.
So it's a nice to have thing.
It sounds really, really cool.
In practice, it's probably
a little limited.
So we'll see how it
goes, though.
Be cool to try at least.
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah, definitely.
So should we just summarize
what we've been over?
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, I
mean, in terms of--
should people even be building
sync clients and
virtual file systems?
And I would say--
I mean, yeah.
If you can--
ALI AFSHAR: I would say,
strongly, yes.
Why not?
STEVE BAZYL: I mean, especially
a virtual file
system, I think, is actually
something that has some good
practical uses with--
we see a lot of apps like
these on Windows
virtualization machines in the
cloud, where you can run
native apps through
remote desktops.
Those are cases where it doesn't
really make sense for
them to try to sync everything
in Drive, especially when they
have these kind of very
ephemeral machines that come
and go, and they get
spun up and down.
And a virtual file system is
perfect for that case.
And a custom sync client,
there's probably a lot of
value that you can add if
you have a good idea.
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah, so, I mean,
already there are a number of
custom sync clients out there.
They're all slightly different,
and they approach
things in a different way.
I hope we got across that it's
actually technically quite a
tricky problem.
So each one has their
own benefits.
There's one that's targeted
for OS X. There's a
Linux-based one.
There there's various ones.
And I'd advise you to try them
out, read their code, because
it is useful, and they will
have had to solve some of
these problems.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, definitely.
But yeah, it's a really
fun problem to solve.
The hopefully--
ALI AFSHAR: If you like
that kind of thing.
STEVE BAZYL: I like it.
I think it's actually
really fun trying
to solve these problems.
And then even if you're not
doing anything like that, but
are just new to Drive and are
trying to get your head around
its model, it's useful to
understand these differences.
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah, absolutely.
So what have we talked about?
Well, we spoke about
the use cases.
Why would you want to do this?
Why would you want to treat
Drive as a local file system,
and how that would be.
The key differences, well,
Steve mentioned paths.
We spoke about multiple parents
and the non-uniqueness
of file names and how you would
deal with those things.
And we spoke about some of the
challenges involved in that.
STEVE BAZYL: Right, especially
around disambiguating the file
names and resolving paths.
There's a lot of different
strategies that you can go
around to address those,
depending on whether or not
you're building a sync client
or a virtual file system.
And if you have local storage
that you can use to cache some
of that data--
lots of different strategies.
And you just have to kind of
look at your particular use
case and what you're trying
to accomplish.
But none of these are, I would
say, insurmountable problems.
ALI AFSHAR: No, no.
STEVE BAZYL: They're just little
small things that you
have to kind of deal with.
And they add a little
bit of complexity.
But generally, things that you
can solve with just a little
bit of forethought and have
a tiny bit of code.
ALI AFSHAR: And we mentioned
the asynchronous nature of
Drive in making web requests.
Probably we concluded that
whatever you're doing, you
should do this asynchronously
anyway, even for a local file
system, because that would make
your app more responsive.
And users love responsive
apps.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, for people
used to writing using blocking
calls in their web apps,
yeah, it's a little
bit harder to do.
But it's worth it.
ALI AFSHAR: It's worth it.
And I guess, finally, to end on,
we're really keen to see
what you're writing.
So if you're doing one of these
cool apps, you might
think it's not exactly the use
case for Google Drive.
You might think we don't want
to know about that.
Actually, the more interesting
and strange your app is, the
more likely we are that we
do want to know about it.
STEVE BAZYL: But it
has to be good
interesting and good strange.
ALI AFSHAR: Of course, good
interesting, not bad
interesting.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, I definitely
encourage everyone.
If you are building an app,
whether it's something that is
like this, or just a regular web
app that's integrated with
the drive UI or whatever, find
us on Google+, find us on
Stack Overflow, but reach
out and let us
know what you're building.
ALI AFSHAR: Ask those
difficult questions.
STEVE BAZYL: Especially
on Stack Overflow.
And I think the response time
has been really great so far
in getting answers out there.
But since I'm the developer
advocate and tend to do a
little bit more around one, I'd
love to get an email or
put something on Google+ to just
let me know what you're
doing and see what we
can do to help.
ALI AFSHAR: Great.
Thank you.
Good luck with everything.
STEVE BAZYL: Great.
Thanks everyone.
ALI AFSHAR: Bye-bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]